we've all had a couple of weeks to spend
with fallout 4 now and as you can
imagine that means tons of easter eggs
have been found well I'm sure you guys
have already heard about the fact that
codsworth knows a bunch of names and
then you can pick up holotape minigames
I got five more awesome secrets to show
you that naturally fallout 4 has a lot
of iconic Boston landmarks from Fenway
Park to faneuil hall but obviously the
best of them is far and away the bar
from Cheers Barry down by the water is
an unassuming building it called post
far Prost being the German expression
for Cheers the downstairs bar is a
pretty awesome recreation of the iconic
set from the sitcom which takes place in
boston you'll find a few of your
favorite characters although they're now
missing some of their aliveness they had
four when you process that all these
lovable folks died in the nuclear blast
here there's a tad grim but at least you
get to spend a little time in the bar
where everyone knows your name or used
to know your name at least if you like
me started fallout 3 a bunch of times
and thus became pretty familiar with the
goat test of this easter eggers for you
at the entrance to a town called
Covenant on the way to Diamond City
you'll need to take a test of course it
called the safe test now but the
questions are eerily similar a man
standing outside called Swanson lets you
know that the test is designed to keep
out synthetic people and proceeds to ask
you the familiar series of questions
luckily chances are you'll pass and
mosey on into covenant no matter how
psychotic your answers the wasteland of
fallout has a lot of things that go bang
in it some of which make really really
big bang this easter egg is one of those
while wandering down the road aways
south of diamond city you can happen
upon a massive explosion in a hut in the
middle of nowhere investigating the
debris after the blast uncovers a home
with its roof blown clean off a nail
very dead moonshiner a chemistry station
and
but a great day for that guy iball have
a lot of pop culture references at one
of which appears to be a call back to
jaws it seems like a bigger boat really
would have been a lifesaver given how
this one unfolded venturing down the
coastline will reveal a beastly mutated
dolphin creature beat up on the edge of
a busted boat the toothy feller appears
to be in the middle of chowing down on
the unlucky Quint from the film who's
lying next to his blue bandana and a
machete finally it may be far from the
first time to fall out it's featured
aliens but it's still well worth the
mention there's some speculation over
whether discovering this one is random
or whether it appears after the
completion of a quest but here's what
you can expect a massive UFO crashes
into boston in a fiery nest and you're
alerted to its presence by either your
companions or through a so-called
garbled radio station on your pip-boy if
you travel to oberlin station and head
east you'll discover the wreckage within
which you'll find a wounded and hostile
alien if you decide to kill him you can
take his sweet alien blaster gun for
yourself the alien and his lasa have
been secret encounters in every fallout
game since the first one back in 97 let
me know down in the comments section
what other fallout for easter eggs
you've come across and i will catch you
again next week
you